hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Chapter two of
on Liberty John Stuart Mill is making a
set of arguments for the reasons why we
should not engage in silencing or
suppression of opinions with a few
exceptions being made in later chapters
and among the arguments that he makes is
that it's actually bad for us too if we
think that we have the truth to silence
everything else because we're not going
to hold the truth we're not going to
hold that opinion in the same way when
there's no opposition or contrast to it
and this is a really an interesting
argument that is you know very on point
a lot of people forget about this they
think when we're discussing matters of
freedom of expression and marketplace of
ideas and all these sorts of things they
forget that human beings can hold truths
or hold opinions that they believe to be
true in a variety of ways and one of the
things that that mill is really
concerned about is the danger of truth
if one has actually found it being held
not as a living truth something that
actually fits in with one's life and
motivates oneself and can be a resource
but instead as being what he calls a
dead Dogma now what is a Dogma that is
worth dwelling on this a bit we often
use this term rather pejoratively and by
Mills time it actually come to be viewed
in that way a Dogma originally means
something that has to be believed and
it's it's not originally said in a
religious context although that's where
it probably had the greatest extent
within within Western Christianity
talking about different dogmas of
Christianity right it was used by
philosophers as well the stoic school
and the epicurean school were dogmatic
philosophies in the sense that they said
that dog Motta judgments or opinions
certain of them actually had to be held
in order to fit into that philosophy and
you know at that time it wasn't without
that pejorative sense it wasn't
understood that a dogma would be
something that yeah you just believe in
it and don't think about it or anything
like that as a matter of fact it had to
be part of the living fabric of the
philosophy or it wouldn't work by the
time that mill is writing a Dogma is
something that you you just believe in
and you don't question it and you don't
accept other people trying to you know
take it down or argue against it you
just shut up and let me think what I
want to think and so that's not a living
truth he says that there is a class of
persons who think it enough of a person
a sense and doubtingly to what they
think true though he has no knowledge
whatever of the grounds of the opinion
and could not make a tenable defense of
it against the most superficial
objections that's a good example of a
dogma somebody who is dogmatic today is
holding their belief essentially as a
mere prejudice they were taught that and
that's what they're going to accept he
says such persons if they can once get
their Creed taught from authority
naturally think
no good and some harm comes of it being
allowed to be questioned and I'll say
that in our own time you know more than
a hundred years after mill is writing
this more than 150 actually being anti
dogmatic or being a rationalist or a
believer in logic or stuff like that
that can become just as much a
dogmatically held viewpoint as anything
else as a matter of fact many of the
people that you engage with today who
claim that they are you know scientific
or logical or rational don't have a clue
what those terms actually mean they've
just been taught something and they've
been taught that other ways of thinking
about things are non logical non
rational and if you if you question them
on it all they can do is pair it back
something like a catechism that would
put a religious person to shame there's
a matter of fact a lot of religious
people can't even do their catechism for
the religions that they they buy into so
there's lots of people who do this we
can do this with political doctrines you
know there are people who are on the
left and on the right and plenty of
centrists who have essentially no idea
what they're talking about they just
believe in something in the way of a
mere prejudice and what is a prejudice
it's it's deciding something ahead of
time and then not you know listening to
anything else so he says that there we
go where the influence of these people
prevail and make it nearly impossible
for the received opinion to be rejected
wisely and considerately though it may
be rejected rationally and ignorantly
for to shut out discussion entirely
seldom possible and then it says waiving
this assuming that the true opinion
abides in the mind but abides as a
prejudice a belief independent of and
proof against argument this is not the
way in which truth ought to be held by a
rational being why does he say that
rational beings need to have some sort
of basis some sort of capacity
to explain what it is they believe
doesn't mean that they have to be able
to satisfy everybody else's doubts or
arguments that's not that's not really
the criterion but they they sure have to
be able to say something more than I
just believe this or that's just my my
feeling or I was taught that way they've
got to be able to provide something that
could potentially satisfy and enlighten
another person and so rational beings
need to be able to understand their
beliefs or opinions they need to know
the basis and mill goes on and he says
that this is not knowing the truth truth
is held truth thus held is but one
superstition the more accidentally
clinging to the words which enunciate a
truth it's not to be a rational being
and so he goes on and he says what would
a rational being have to do cultivate
the intellect and judgment and so they
would have to see what other people have
to say when he brings up some
interesting examples here he talks about
geometry and he says that persons who
learn geometry do not simply commit the
theorems to memory they understand and
learn likewise the demonstrations and it
would be absurd to say they remain
ignorant of the grounds of geometric
truths because they never heard anyone
deny and attempted to prove them and he
says the peculiarity of the evidence of
mathematical truths is that all the
argument is on one side there are no
objections but on every subject on which
difference of opinion is possible the
truth depends on a balance to be struck
between two sets of conflicting opinions
we might say there's more than than that
he says even in natural philosophy
there's always some other explanation
possible the same fact some geocentric
theory instead of heliocentric and he
gives some other examples and then he
says when we turn to subjects infinitely
more complicated to morals religion
politics social relations the business
of life three quarters of the arguments
for every disputed opinion consist in
dispelling the appearances which favor
some opinion different from it and
does that in his own works he's doing
that in this very work he's saying well
you know we need to think about the
people who say that we shouldn't allow
free expression of opinion let's see
what their argument actually is he does
this in his work utilitarianism where he
begins by considering the criticisms
made of utilitarianism this is indeed
how a rational person approaches the
truths that they believe in they don't
say well I believe in them so everyone
shut up I'm not gonna listen to you no
no no no no no no all right that's not
that's that's an irrational way of
behaving you have to take in multiple
points of view on complex subjects which
means this requires as mill says
encountering other opinions what is it
like to encounter other opinions he goes
on and he says if we want to do justice
to arguments or bring them into real
contact with our own mind he says it
isn't it's not enough that he should
hear the arguments of adversaries from
his own teachers presented as they state
them and accompanied by what they offers
reputations so you can't rely on sort of
a textbook or a you know reconstruction
by the others this was actually a big
problem a little bit of a you know
example here in the manuals of
philosophy and theology that we're being
relied upon in largely in religious
circles but you know there's there's
plenty of examples of this done in
similar ways just not called manuals in
secular circles where they would say
well this is what Kant says and it would
be some reconstruction of Kant with the
the best parts usually taken out and
some summaries they say well this is why
count is wrong we don't need to talk
about content Moore or Descartes or you
know this person or that person you know
in the manuals if it was from atomistic
perspective the it would conclude with
and this is why Thomas Aquinas solved
this issue if it's from a Cartesian
perspective of this is why cart has done
so if it's from a you know modern
secular
perspective it would be this is why this
person has shown that all of this is
wrong that manual list approach as
opposed to a genuinely dialectical
approach where you take on what your
opponents have to say is going to
produce dogmatic and therefore nonliving
approaches to truth it's great for
producing people who in artificial
situations or in very restricted places
can pair it back arguments but it's not
producing people who can think
rationally and saying oh you know
actually maybe maybe there's something
good to this this other argument over
here we better assimilate it so he says
that the rational position for for a
person would you know be to be in real
contact with these things he must be
able to hear them from persons who
actually believe them he must know them
in the most plausible and persuasive
form he must feel the whole force of the
difficulty which the true view of the
subject has to encounter in disposed of
else he will never really possess
himself of the portion of truth which
meets and removes that difficulty then
he says ninety-nine and a hundred of
what are called educated people are in
this condition even those who can argue
fluently for their opinions their
conclusion may be true but it might be
false for anything they know they've
never thrown themselves into the mental
position of those who think differently
from them and considered what such
persons may have to say so they don't
know the doctrine which they themselves
profess that's a problem that's a
serious problem does this mean that you
have to listen endlessly to the
positions of others no but then there
needs to be some contact with us so we
can't repress opinions even if there we
think that they're false because we're
depriving ourself of the possibility of
believing in the truths that we believe
in as living truths and not mere dogmas
not mere prejudices not things that
we've assimilated and are sort of you
know parroting back the way that a
polemicist or a partisan would do
there's also a discussion here that's
quite good about the restriction of
discussion to an elite he has in mind
this view that would say on these he
brings up theological and philosophical
questions but we could easily say this
about economic questions or about policy
you know social and political questions
or even about aesthetics we say well the
ordinary person belief is good good
enough for them tell them what they need
to believe tell them to shut up if new
doctrines come around but we allow there
to be an elite where there's there's
plenty of discussion and Mills says well
I mean to begin with that's kind of a
problem because you're depriving all
these other people of the opportunity to
engage in it but you're also not gonna
have a wide range of discussion and
that's not going to be good for anything
he says if the mischievious operation of
the absence of free discussion when the
received opinions are true were confined
to leaving men ignorant to the grounds
of those opinions and my thought be
thought that this if an intellectual is
no moral evil and does not affect the
worth of the opinions regarded in their
influence on the character the fact is
however that not only the grounds of the
opinion are forgotten in the absence of
discussion but often the meaning of the
opinion itself so we don't want to
entrust this dialectical engagement of
ideas merely to an elite I mean now this
leads into another key consideration
there's a lot of ways in which people
believe some set of doctrines and dogmas
some some you know truths whether they
were revealed from on high or came up
from the masses originally or you know
we're in some best-selling book that now
we all have to buy into there's a lot of
ways people believe that and turn those
opinions that they hold to be truths
into something that's dry something
that's
dead formulaic so without some sort of
opposition or contrast what here mill is
calling a Creed becomes formulaic and he
says that here we go the words which
convey it cease to suggest ideas or
suggest a small portion of those they
were originally employed to communicate
instead of a vivid conception and living
belief that remained only a few phrases
retained by rote or if any part the
shell and husk only of the meaning has
retained the finer essence being lost he
says it this is illustrated in the
experience of almost all ethical
doctrines and religious creeds they're
full of meaning vitality to those who
originate them into the direct disciples
of their originators their meaning
continues to be felt an undiminished
strength and is perhaps brought out into
even fuller consciousness so long as the
struggle lasts to give the doctrine or
Creed an ascendancy over other Creed's
at lastly there prevails and becomes the
general opinion or its progress stops
when either of these results has become
apparent controversy on the subject
flags and gradually dies away now why
the see it sounds really great well
truth one without that contrast the
truth is not held in the same way as
mill goes on he says those who hold this
view have generally inherited not
adopted it conversion from one of these
doctrines to another being an
exceptional fact occupies little place
in the thoughts with their professors
and eventually he says there's a decline
in the living power of the doctor people
believe things but it doesn't matter
because they don't actually put it into
action it's not as as you will go on and
says a little bit later it's not
integrated with the rest of their nature
he says that what we see is
the Creed remains as it were outside the
mind encrusting and petrifying it
against all other influences addressed
to the higher parts of our nature
manifesting its power by not suffering
any fresh and living convection
conviction to get in but doing nothing
for the mind or heart except standing
Sentinel over them to keep them vacant
so an idea or set of ideas a doctrine
become something dead something ossified
something indeed in the classic sense of
the term stultifying rendering a person
into a stillness a fool making them
imprudent and he has another great
example here he talks about was quite
interesting we have these linguistic
passages right that we call proverbs or
adages he calls them truisms and he says
that when we're thinking about prudence
and knowledge of life says all languages
and literature's are full of general
observations on life both as to what is
and how to conduct oneself in it
observations which everyone knows which
everyone repeats or hears with
acquiescence which are received as
truisms yet of which most people first
truly learn the meaning when experience
generally of a painful kind has made it
a reality to them so he says how often
when smarting under some unforeseen
misfortune or disappointment does a
person call the mind some proverb or
common saying familiar to him all his
life the meaning of which if he'd ever
before felt it as he does now would have
saved him from the calamity and he says
it's only when we actually have this
conflict this this generation of we
might call it agonistic dialectic
between thoughts and trying to apply
them in real life that we really know
what it is that we believe so it's very
important if truths are going to be held
in the way that a rational being holds
truths that were encountering other
opinions that we think to be false
otherwise we risk to generating into
mere sets of prejudices
you